there is a great review by Anderson and
colleagues where they kind of
highlighted the research indicating that
high fiber intake is associated with
lower risk of coronary heart disease
stroke hypertension diabetes obesity and
certain gastrointestinal diseases there
is also a different review paper by
Barber and colleagues where they pointed
out that fibers inversely associated
with all-cause mortality along with
mortality from cardiovascular disease
and all cancers overall and of course A
lot of times people hear that and they
say Okay correlation Association that's
all observational that's a bunch of crap
but there is a pretty strong mechanism
mechanistic basis from randomized
controlled trials by which you can
really clearly draw a line
uh between a causative mechanism that is
reliably induced by high fiber intake
and the types of outcomes that we're
seeing in these studies so uh when it
comes to fiber it is a very strong and
very comprehensive case for the fact
that fiber by and large has a very
positive impact in the diet and if
you're wondering what an advisable
intake for fiber might be a very basic
recommendation that you see all the time
is about 14 grams of fiber per thousand
calories in the diet so for a 2 000
calorie diet that would be 28 grams of
fiber per day for example and the reason
that they scale that recommendation to
caloric intake is because as anyone
who's done some pretty restrictive
dieting has observed it can be really
hard to get high fiber intake on a very
low calorie diet I still try my best to
do that
um like you know if I'm down on a you
know 15 1800 calorie diet I'd do try to
get higher than that 14 per thousand
calorie number just to try to stay close
to my typical fiber intake but without
question it gets very very challenging
because where there's fiber you're
usually going to find other non-fiber
carbohydrate that's going to come with
it so when you start cutting carbs and
total calories out of your diet a lot of
times you will see that the fiber tends
to go with it a little bit but yeah I
mean fiber is is really fascinating in
terms of its impact on a variety of
different Health outcomes and there's
even some less obvious associations that
have been observed so
some Studies have found that fiber
intake is associated with better immune
function lower chronic inflammation
levels and even a lower risk of
depression and those are some of the
outcomes where it gets a little bit
harder to draw a really strong
mechanistic link but I do think one
fascinating kind of related area of
research is in the realm of short chain
fatty acids so when we consume dietary
fiber and other non-digestible or
partially digestible carbohydrates when
those start to ferment in the digestion
process what we see is that they they do
lead to the production of several
different short chain fatty acids and
other Associated metabolites and those
short chain fatty acids and similar
metabolites they do seem to have some
pretty wide-ranging physiological
effects that we are in the process of
elucidating and fully starting to
understand but we're really not there
yet uh so I remember a few years back I
dug into the research on short chain
fatty acids and it's a very very
fascinating body of literature but it
it's cut it kind of reminds me a bit of
if you were to dig into the gut
microbiome literature right now you can
see the glimpses of like okay this is
definitely important in in some capacity
but the question is how do we make that
useful how do we act upon that yeah and
for what things is it truly causative so
there's there's much to be learned there
but
basically what I wanted to do with this
segment was uh kind of highlight the
fact that uh you've not lost your mind
despite what you're seeing more and more
on social media fiber uh within the
academic world and within the world of
anyone working clinically in nutrition
fiber is still embraced as a very very
uh healthful addition to the diet within
the types of intakes that I've described
yeah
um now one thing I should acknowledge
is that there are some instances with
certain gut-related pathologies and
clinical conditions where short-term
fiber reduction is part of the treatment
process so if you go into seek medical
treatment for uh certain specific
gastrointestinal conditions they might
for a time put you on a pretty
restrictive diet that eliminates a lot
of fibrous foods but when you look into
the clinical literature about those
types of interventions it's almost
always framed as a short-term
Elimination Diet with the purpose where
you you do that Elimination Diet you
remove foods that could be exacerbating
symptoms and once you reach a point
where symptoms have subsided you start
reintroducing foods and generally
building fiber back up to a tolerable
level yeah so a lot of people have
looked into some of these short-term
interventions of fiber restrict action
and said oh man if fiber's so bad for
your gut I'm just going to restrict it
all the time and that would be a
misapplication of that research and
generally an inadvisable thing to do
especially if you already have an
otherwise healthy functioning GI system
with no symptoms yeah